you've got data and you know how to get
it in the cloud storage
now let's talk about who you want to
have access to it
i'm in a sharing mood so i'll give you
permission
to learn more today on cloud storage
bytes we're talking about controlling
access
keeping the right people in the loop and
the wrong people
out of it let's dive in
[Music]
when you first create a bucket you'll
need to decide whether you want to apply
permissions using uniform or
fine-grained access in general we
recommend using uniform bucket level
access
this method allows you to use im to
manage all of your permissions for all
of the objects in a bucket
this might mean rethinking how you are
picturing your storage approach
let's imagine you run a dog daycare and
you take photos of the dogs every day
so their owners can log in and see what
their pet has been up to if you have a
bucket of photos where you're storing
all of those
then you would need to set the
permissions for each individual photo so
that you aren't sharing
remy's photos with willow's owner
if however you create a bucket for each
owner
then you can grant permissions for that
bucket lowering the risk of data
exposure
now if willow's owner adds a second
person to the account
one permission change will share all of
willow's photos
that's because im aims to make
authentication easier by giving you full
control and visibility
cloud i am provides a unified view into
the security control of your entire
organization
across your various google cloud
services
this means there's one place to check
for granting and reviewing permissions
for employees
dog owners visitors other franchise
locations and more
so that's how uniform access works for
cloud storage
if however you know you're going to need
to manage permissions at the object
level for a given bucket
then you can select fine-grained access
this option is mainly for integrations
that rely on legacy access control
systems for interoperability with
other services in addition to choosing
between uniform and fine-grained access
when creating your bucket
you also have options for special
controls such as signed urls for
accessing an object through a link for a
set amount of time
or signed policy documents to specify
what can be uploaded to a bucket
or credential access boundaries to
restrict the permissions that are
available to an oauth 2.0 access token
to learn more about these options be
sure to check out the documentation
and don't forget to subscribe give us a
like and let us know what features of
cloud storage you'd like to learn more
about
thanks for joining us for this quick
bite of cloud storage
[Music]